hey it's Justine and today we are in
Catalina and we are testing out the
Apple watch Ultra as a dive computer now
originally I planned on coming to
Catalina and getting my Open Water
certification but I went to the Maldives
a month ago and ended up just doing it
early now this is an entirely different
experience because this is diving in
cold water and in the Maldives the water
was 87 degrees it was so warm you didn't
actually have to wear a wetsuit but here
it's a little bit different and there's
so much more gear involved so I've got
this seven millimeter super thick
wetsuit when I first got my Ocean band
it was so large on my arm and I didn't
actually understand the concept because
I'd never dove or really ever worn a
wetsuit before is it needs to be large
enough to be able to go over top of a
thick wetsuit or even a thin wetsuit and
this wetsuit is actually so thick that I
needed an extender so the app that we're
using is the oceanic Plus app now
there's an Apple Watch app and then
there's a companion app that goes to
your phone so both of those will sync
and work together there's also an
oceanic Apple watch face which is kind
of cool because on here it'll give you
all of the things that you need you've
got your dive planner okay to fly time
which is something that I didn't know
that you have to actually wait time
between your dive before you can fly
it's got a bunch of other really cool
features but now my friends it's time to
go hop in the water so let's come
foreign
[Music]
okay so we're gonna do a little once
over here of the year since I've only
basically Dove like once in my life I
need a little refresher course I am open
water certified but I want to know as
much as I can at all times so all right
we've got all our gear this is also all
brand new yeah no worries yeah
[Music]
all right
I don't remember all this part yeah it's
kind of important
I feel like a sausage because like a
sausage is inside of like a sausage
casing like that's what I feel like
right now I gotta breathe
[Music]
all right I think everything's good
top in
[Music]
everything
[Applause]
[Music]
oh man we just got back from the first
dive in cold water for me and it was it
was freezing but it took me a while to
kind of get used to it and once I got
down there though it was okay my boy and
Steve haven't quite figured that out yet
but uh yeah I'm excited for the next
time
[Music]
all right dive briefing time so I've got
the Oceana Gap up and we have our
location planner so since we're diving
in Catalina yeah we got our temperature
tied maybe on this dive we'll plan to go
to about 50 feet aim for the swim
platform it's one of the refracts in the
park so no Deco planner we just did a
dive so what is this kind of determine
um it's going to tell us how long we can
stay at our current depth for our next
dive uh takes into account what we just
did and so we'll say We'll enter the
info how long we're going to stay on the
surface until the next dive and we'll
add in the depth that we want to go to
it'll tell us exactly how much we can do
all right looks like we're ready to go
out looks like I got a plan let's go get
wet let's do it
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Music]
my favorite part now of diving is
getting out and seeing all of my stats
seeing how far I've Dove seeing the
depth seeing the water temperature and
with the oceanic Apple Watch app it just
automatically syncs to the iPhone app so
I can go in and see all of this
information here are my two Dives today
so our first one we want a max depth of
44 feet our next one we went 53 feet and
it's cool because this shows you your
depth I was struggling on this first one
trying to get my buoyancy we do it for
34 minutes water temperature 58 degrees
so cold that's where we are so I can go
in and add some things about the dive
like the visibility the surface
condition there was a little bit of
current visibility was not as good on
this last dive as it was on the first
one and there we go we are all logged
for our Dives today
[Music]
oh my goodness I had absolutely the best
time here in Catalina diving now to
catch some of you up who may not know I
was terrified of the water about a month
and a half ago I didn't even want to put
my head under water whenever I did the
original Apple Watch review and in that
review I said that the Apple watch Ultra
might be the thing to get me to be scuba
certified so now here we are on Catalina
and the two days of diving that we did
here was quite an experience coming from
87 degree incredibly warm tropical
weather where I was wearing a very small
wetsuit a little shorty like basically
nothing at all to hear where I would be
wearing the equivalent of a snow suit
definitely a whole new experience at
incredible instructor rain like the
weather this is Instagram and he was so
awesome we did a little refresher course
the first day and the first dive a huge
thank you to Oceanic for hooking it up
with all of the gear now Oceanic is
actually the company that makes the
Apple Watch app on the Apple watch Ultra
so a huge thank you to them again for
making this all happen and also giving
me the confidence to be able to go out
and do this in the first place so to get
to Catalina we took the 6 a.m ferry so I
got up at like 3 30 so that first day of
diving we were all absolutely exhausted
at 3 30 a.m this morning I did not feel
like having breakfast so got this on the
ferry over we met up with Nick who works
at Oceanic and Rain he walked me through
all of the things that I needed to know
I did learn everything that I needed to
know to pass my certification but
getting this little refresher course on
day one of all of my gear all of the
hand signals everything that I needed to
know to be safe in the water was
definitely great to have the refresher
especially because I got all this new
gear from Oceanic so now being able to
get familiar with gear that is my very
own is such a huge difference if it
wasn't for the Apple watch Ultra I don't
think that I would be diving and I think
that's the really cool thing is I feel
like this is such an accessible device
for a lot of people now obviously you
should always have a second dive
computer no matter what device you're
using you should always have a backup
because anything can happen I mean you
know a shark could come up and just take
this off of you and say hey that looks
nice I think I want to wear that now so
the first day of diving was a little
sketchy uh getting into the water it was
freaking freezing beyond anything that I
could have prepared my body for now I
did have a seven mil wetsuit so it was
very thick we saw lots of fish I also
thought that the Garibaldi was a
goldfish but then I remembered that
goldfish are freshwater fish and this is
not fresh water and that in fact is the
California state fish so that is
probably something that I should know I
think my next investment is going to be
a little fish book so I can check off
all the creatures that I've seen in the
water the really cool thing about diving
in Catalina are these kelp forests I
mean this kelp is just so remarkable I
mean it's coming all the way from the
bed of the sea to the top and it's just
floating through there
such a cool feeling the other cool thing
is we saw this massive sea bass we
actually saw a bunch of them but this
shot right here I got still startled
because I did not even see him next to
me and I turned around I was like what
are you doing there buddy we also saw a
Shark uh I did not actually see the
shark in person because I was so
freezing and this was our last dive of
the day and I was like guys I gotta go
I'm I'm actually shivering and I gotta
peace out but Devin who's an incredible
videographer he does so many amazing
underwater shots that I'm so grateful
that he was able to come on the shoot
with me we got a really cool underwater
housing for the Sony a7s III and he went
and got some really cool shots of the
shark now the Oceana Gap is great for
snorkeling as well so if you're not a
diver you can actually use this to
snorkel you can track your entry points
your depth and how far you swam and
that's actually just free with the
oceanic app but if you do want to dive
and get access to your dive planning and
tissue loading there is a subscription
which is kind of great because for a lot
of people who may not be frequent divers
the Apple watch is great and you don't
have to buy a full dedicated dive
computer you've already got one right
here on your wrist now my second day of
diving was so much more fun I was so
much more comfortable because the first
day that first dive I was still getting
used to the Gear figuring out my
buoyancy I thought I would be a lot more
terrified than I was it actually wasn't
bad at all I really thought that the
cold water was going to affect me more I
did get some cramping in my legs my feet
were just like feeling a little weird
like my whole body just kind of felt
different and once I got used to that it
made the second day that much better but
we had so much fun and we saw so many
cool things and I think my favorite
thing was this little Garibaldi who was
building its little nest and anytime
anything would get in its little area it
would go and pick it up and move it out
immediately it was actually really
really cute did a little exploring I got
to use rain's flashlight and really see
what I could see my favorite thing that
I saw though was this huge freaking
Lobster I mean look at this thing it's
massive it's got a little tentacle out
like ready to come and get you one of
the things that I really like about this
though is it gives you an alert when you
need to make your safety stop so it
gives you a countdown of how long you
need to stay at that depth before you
completely Ascend to the top so you find
yourself at the surface and you need to
go grab some weights or I don't know you
forgot something or you have to go to
the bathroom
it will give you a countdown that will
let you go back down to the surface and
continue that dive so you won't have to
count it as a second dive so right now
we've got 27 seconds to hop back in
we're not going to be doing that just
yet
because I'm a really chilly I had so
much fun on Catalina and I look forward
to getting my sister dive certified so
we can do some really fun diving trips
if you guys have any suggestions of some
gear that I should get some tech that I
should check out places that I should
dive animals that I need to be on the
lookout for any tips and tricks please
leave them in the comments below because
I am right now I'm like a sponge I am
taking in all of the information I am
learning and I want to know it all so
thank you guys again for all of the tips
that you did give me in my first video
where I talked about this and I look
forward to many many more with that I'll
see you guys in the next video If you
guys like this please give it a thumbs
up for me conquering my fears I think
that I deserve it don't forget to
comment below and subscribe if you
haven't already also be sure to hit the
bell for notifications when I post new
videos and if you want to see any other
ones I'll put them here on the end
screen I'll see you guys in the next one
bye